Welcome back. Up to this point, we've really only been working with one
variable. Analyzing the mean and the standard deviation, and seeing where a
sample mean falls on this distribution. And if that's typical, or not so
typical. But now we're going to focus on two variables. With two variables, we
have a different design. This means we need to change how we collect our data,
how we visualize our data. However, our analysis is going to be pretty similar,
and you'll see later. Now that we're starting to discuss two variables instead
of just one, let's start by thinking about two variables that might be related
to each other. For example height and weight. People who are taller usually
weigh more. Or maybe time spent studying and your grade. May be the more time
you spent studying the better your grade will be. Heres the weird one. The
outdoor temperature and angle injuries. I read this article the other day, that
said that the warmer weather causes the people to wear more flip flops and
sandals that make your ankles more prone to injuries. Do you have any other
ideas? Post about it in the forums, and maybe include some information that you
found that shows this relationship.